we are only a week away from what will
be an election that will change the
future of the United States and I would
argue the world either we will have the
historic first ever election of a female
president to the United States women
making up more than half of this country
yet we have never had a female president
that may happen next week or we may see
uh a man who is I'm I'm confident he's a
man anything else I can't really say
with certitude who seems to be clueless
about most everything that relates to
being president of the United States a
president elect who just a month later
if indeed it is Donald Trump will uh be
the subject of a child rape case hearing
in a court of law either way this is
going to be historic we just don't yet
know in what way history will be made
but we should see what the numbers tell
us now that we are just a week away
we're going to look at three things
because the polls have indeed tightened
over the last couple of weeks we will
look at national polls we will look at a
state-by-state analysis and we will also
look at a few different
fivethirtyeight.com forecasts let's
begin indeed with the Real Clear
Politics average of recent polls and
list of recent polls we had just a
couple of weeks ago Hillary Clinton
leading the Real Clear Politics average
by about 6.5 last week we saw that
shrink to about five and now Hillary
Clinton's Real Clear Politics average
lead over Donald Trump in a four-way
race is just 2.2 percentage points she
is still leading almost every recent
poll just not nearly by the same margin
that she was a couple of weeks ago but
this is just nationally what about
state-by-state well it has tightened
there as well we will start with the
electoral vote dot-com electoral count
map and this is based on state-by-state
polling Hillary Clinton still well ahead
323 electoral votes currently on her
side to 15 for Donald Trump but Trump
has surged from about a hundred and
seventy predicted electoral votes to
over 200 you still need 270 electoral
votes to win and Donald Trump is not
there but it has also tightened when you
look at the National map and we will
also look at the 272 win dot-com
electoral map where it is closer but
still not that close electoral of the
electoral map at 270 to win dot-com has
it at 258 for Hillary Clinton and 157
for Donald Trump with a hundred and
twenty three electoral votes in the sort
of undecided area when you look at this
map though I don't know that i buy it I
mean Wisconsin is undecided here I think
that will go to Hillary Clinton North
Carolina is a isn't up up for grabs in
this map I believe that will go to
Hillary Clinton and that would do it no
matter what else happens uh so that is
something to think about and then lastly
what does nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com forecast say and
you'll will show you how this has
changed over time and when you look at
of the the sort of mid-october high of
Hillary Clinton up to a ninety percent
chance of winning according to nate
silver's fivethirtyeight.com forecast
that has pretty consistently decreased
to the seventh roughly right now
according to the fivethirtyeight.com
forecast there's about a three in four
chance that Hillary Clinton will win a
week from today and about a one in four
chance for Donald Trump one other thing
i want to show you this is super
interesting i've mentioned this but I've
never showed it this is according to
fivethirtyeight.com the chance that any
one state has of being the decider in
next Tuesday's election and you'll
notice that at the top of the list this
we're looking at the left column here if
you're looking with me Florida has a 13
point nine percent chance of being the
decider in other words of being the
tipping point state uh in the upcoming
election Pennsylvania just below Florida
at twelve point seven percent
then Michigan so Florida Pennsylvania
and Michigan together the the odds are
quite good that they could be nearly one
in to that one of those three states
will tip the election and of course uh
Pennsylvania and Michigan pretty clearly
going in the direction of Hillary
Clinton Florida still more of an up for
grabs so one week to go we will see what
happens the the key takeaway here is
vote I already voted on friday i am done
i now don't have to worry about it early
voting available in many many states the
funniest thing is when the Trump
supporters do and don't believe the
polls Pat because when Hillary Clinton
was just crushing it the polls are
rigged you can't believe the polls it's
all bogus now that the polls have
tightened the Trump supporters are
coming out of the woodwork saying look
at the polls it's now tied wait a second
if you didn't believe them when Trump
was losing by seven on average why do
you now believe them when it's within
the margin of error it's just what's
convenient for them at the time isn't it
and the race is closer now that's an
arguable but if you look at the twenty
twelve election a week out it was
neck-and-neck in that race too and Obama
won by four points this map wasn't going
to be good for any Republican let alone
agon like Donald Trump the the takeaway
again is do not stay home go and vote
between now and november eighth if you
can or on november eight unless you're
trump supporter then go november 28th or
whatever it was that that at some point
is campaign accidentally put out